he has flex your [ __ ] at the
Philadelphia Eagles how are you doing
I'm fine if you don't mind I'm just
gonna front load the interview by saying
please don't bring your full weight on
top of every answer that I ask you two a
question okay okay you don't bring my
school wait don't bring your foot
because I you know I'm the quarterback
of this show and just just when you
answer I still want you to bring the
answer but I want you to just put the
weight to the side a little bit instead
of landing directly on top of the answer
to my question can you do that all right
yeah cool I don't know if we need to go
over any film have a full discussion we
need to do that I think I understand
another thing because that doesn't sound
easy to do on a football field Fletcher
is it no it's not no it's not it's not
easy to to not land on top of a
quarterback especially with your
momentum going down but I mean and I
still matching us to do that and which
was hard to adjust I think but I think
you know we're doing the job better and
players doing the job better
so what conversations have you and your
defensive line or anybody on that
defensive group had on this new rule and
emphasis in the NFL this year Fletcher
well I think the biggest thing is we
talked about I'm not talking with Chris
Chris have you know had one called on
him but he said I asked him what made
him call it and I think the biggest
thing was it was the separation he said
you had time to kind of like change
directions but at the same time we
played this game full speed and then you
know especially I landed on top of them
and what came with duty this heart is
really hard to start 315 pounds you know
but they expect us to to UM to try to do
it and my teammates especially guys in
the d-line room you know we you know
gonna try to adjust that way we're not
getting penalized and you know her 19
with you know set reflect the wounds so
walk me through this whole what do you
mean by separation and was this
described to Chris long on Thursday
night by the official in real time well
it was the time I asked a question about
hunting you know it was more of him
being blocked into the guy I'm probably
talking about all this
all different no penalty then actually
landed on top of the court a bit but you
didn't say that you know that there's a
little separation and you know time is
slow up in but it's hard it's really
hard when you planted came full-speed it
I've said it before it I'm not ascared
and I'm not afraid to say that Candice
you know I don't think anything to slow
us down because you know we go out there
and you know so we got that I do play
full speed and try not to get hurt well
speaking of hard every single time we
talked about this on NFL gameday morning
with say Kurt Warner Michael Irvin any
time I've talked about it with Terrell
Davis Deion Sanders winning the
Superbowl and repeating is hard because
you are basically the target every
single time you're out there as opposed
to the previous season usually when you
win the Super Bowl
have you already sensed that belief
you've got your Congress I mean me in a
way you sense it and then and then in
another way I think you know it's really
hard because you know that locker room
has changed since last year I think the
main thing is is to get the guys this
you know that's new to the team you know
we're working up those guys open arms
and you know just write off that you
know let them know how we do things
around here and the biggest thing is
around the building be yourself have fun
but you know also um you know you need
to you know focus when when it's game
time so I think the hardest thing and
you know the most important thing that
we need to do as a team is just you know
just stay focused you know in practice
every day and you know and on our
opponent and just go out and you know
they just keep the game plan but I've
talked to a lot of people and they say
you know going back to back is you know
it's not easy so in terms of your
opponent this week do you believe
Fletcher Cox in fits magic is fits magic
real we're not in through 400 close I
mean you gotta gotta respect it yeah
they opened up you know especially guys
in our room that means you know we know
where it starts it's gonna start with us
getting after the quarterback getting
hit on the quarterback good sex
and you know helping the guys in the
back end and where they're not you know
just you know covering all day so you
know we've saw the tape and he threw the
ball around pretty good and it's gonna
be a good ball game so he said one of
those things when you're watching the
tape you're like that's Ryan Fitzpatrick
out there that's fit that's do you ever
have that conversation yeah I mean I
played against him before we was when
they was in with the kick and a third of
all around pretty good and I think the
biggest thing is realizes he's more
athletic and people give him he can run
you know to be in the league you know 14
years he's not scared to tuck the ball
and take off running so we got a pair of
tension in that and be disciplined in
our rush and uh and I think would be
good
yeah Saints didn't sack him once
Fletcher not a single about it okay
house carson wentz looking to you he's
good I mean he's running around in
practice you know bringing a lot of
energy you know I know he's ready to be
back and you know he's always a
important part important player to the
team so you know I'll be happy to get
back out there man he's just running
around and being itself so he looks the
same to you in the car to miss Carson I
mean he takes the reps and the scout
team just going against us and uh you
know obviously we stay away from him to
be smart because you know he's the
franchise quarterback so you know he
just running around and to me he's just
he's Ben Carson you know a couple more
minutes here with Fletcher Cox what do
you think of a calm act right on the
outside of the season I mean I was I was
surprised to see that I mean you know my
take on it is I mean is you relegated
players like that you know around the
league you know and every you know
father Suzy was gonna play like that and
you know he's a guy that's proven and
you know he's a great player he started
on on a Monday night where he went out
and and and it dominated a gank he's
he's a guy he's a great player well what
does it mean to a locker room do you
think when somebody gets traded instead
of being paid or what's going on across
state with the Steelers where somebody's
so crucial or has been so crucial a team
and
and is holding out or not appearing
because the team isn't paying him what
do you think that does to a locker room
no I mean at the same time I feel like
that you know as I've been in that same
situation and you know I just feel like
its players we just have to understand
and play our part what do you know and
just know that it is a business side so
I mean at the same time you know player
got it you know it's his problem and you
know and he know that we all understand
the business side of of you know a
player not showing up and you know I'm
I'm 100% with those players that you
know that that does because I did it
myself so I just can't you know just go
out and you know just bash somebody for
you know not showing up yeah I mean cuz
that that's been the conversation that
I've had again with some former players
some Hall of Fame players about what's
going on with levy on bail and in in
Pittsburgh Fletcher that that it's it's
everybody is going to be in that I guess
management negotiation crosshairs at
some point and the fact that anybody
would verbalize about somebody else's
business approach is kind of surprising
were you and everybody in your locker
room surprised by that coming out of
Pittsburgh only I don't know which I
mean all I know is I'm here and in our
locker room and I know the group of guys
that we have and you know the great
teammates that I do have and they always
you know have each other back you know
and I do notice coming out of your
locker room a lot of comments about how
much fun you guys have and sometimes the
Patriots don't do you kind of like
pushing that button on the New England
fan that you have more fun and you beat
them last year I think you know our you
know the culture around here is
different in the coach videos there I
think you know coach coach Peterson
always just tell us a man you know have
fun
sososo year you know I saw your good
side you know have a good character and
you know enjoy each other because you
know at the end of the day you know we
all we got and you know I think that's
was I
what makes it so fun how often have you
worn your Super Bowl ring um I've worn
it once was the night I got it I worked
at night and it's actually been in my
safe everything why you don't just like
every now and then just take it out put
it on well I have ahead of time I mean I
mean no I mean I think I watch a couple
special events but I think you know you
know sometime here now I probably put it
on and go out into a nice dinner or a
nice Ugandan you know get a chance to
show it off yeah it's a pretty looking
ring too I mean it's huge it's monster
big like it's like I did I guess that's
why it's in the safe right oh yeah
especially my treatments are 17 what
hold on a second that's your ring size
yeah 17 yeah okay
what's your shoe size 13 so your ring
size bigger than your shoe size correct
that's amazing Fletcher Hey look
appreciate you taking the time good luck
beatin fits magic this weekend thank you
no you laughs like it doesn't exist I
think it exists I never did it seems
real it certainly seemed real in New
Orleans last week good luck down the
line Fletcher I really enjoy our chats
let's talk let's talk sooner rather than
later
all right thank you I got an ad F Cox
with two x's underscore 91 on Twitter
Fletcher Cox here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience